WE ARE AMERICANS.
RIGHT NOW, IT IS OUR DUTY.
AT THE MOMENT, A LOT OF OUR
LEADERS ARE NOT BEING BRAVE.
THEY ARE ALLOWING THE MOB TO RUN
RAMPANT.
TONIGHT, NEW LEAKED AUDIO FROM
CHICAGO, EXACTLY WHAT WAS GOING
ON BEHIND THE SCENES.
IT’S REMARKABLE AND NOT
SURPRISING.
CHIEF BREAKING NEWS
CORRESPONDENT TRACE GALLAGHER
HAS IT ALL ON TAPE.
>> THIS WAS A CONFERENCE CALL ON
SUNDAY, MAY 31ST TO TALK ABOUT
CHICAGO’S RESPONSE TO THE
WIDESPREAD LOOTING.
ON THE CALL WHERE
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT AN OLDER
WOMAN INCLUDING ALDERMAN RAYMOND
LOPEZ, ONE OF THE MAYOR’S
HARSHEST CRITICS.
FOR CONTEXT, ON THE DAY OF THE
CONFERENCE CALL, CHICAGO HAD 699
ARRESTS, MOSTLY LOOTERS, THERE
WERE 48 SHOOTINGS, 17 HOMICIDES,
AND ALDERMAN LOPEZ ACCUSE THE
MAYOR OF BEING UNDERPREPARED AS
THE LOOTING SPREAD SAYING HIS
WARD HAD BECOME A VIRTUAL
WAR ZONE.
LISTEN.
>> HAVE OUR NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
ALREADY OBLITERATED.
IT’S TOO LATE.
WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH A BETTER
PLAN BECAUSE MY FEAR IS ONCE
THEY ARE DONE LOOTING IN WRITING
AND WHATEVER IS GOING TO HAPPEN
TONIGHT, GOD HELP US, WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THEY START GOING
AFTER RESIDENTS?
GOING INTO THE NEIGHBORHOODS?
ONCE THEY START TRYING TO BREAK
DOWN PEOPLES DOORS BECAUSE THEY
THINK THEY GOT SOMETHING.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE HERE TO
ANTAGONIZE AND INSIGHT, AND
YOU’VE GOT THEM ALL PUMPED
TONIGHT.
TODAY, THEY WON’T GO TO BED AT
8:00.
WALKING AROUND RIGHT NOW JUST
WAITING TO SETTLE SOME SCORES.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
>> Tucker:>> THE ALDERMAN WASN’T
EXAGGERATING.
IN AN ENTIRE STRIP MALL WAS
BURNED DOWN BUT WHEN HE FINISHED
SPEAKING, MAYOR LIGHTFOOT
REFUSED TO RESPOND AND FINALLY
SHE DID, WATCH.
>> IF YOU THINK.
>> WHO ARE YOU TO TELL ME I AM
FULL OF [BLEEP]?
>> IF YOU THINK WE ARE NOT
READY, LET THE NEIGHBORHOOD GO
UP, NOTHING INTELLIGENT THAT I
CAN SAY TO YOU.
>> MAYBE YOU SHOULD COME OUT AND
SEE WHAT’S GOING ON.
>> THAT IS THE STUPIDEST THING I
HAVE EVER HEARD.
I UNDERSTAND YOU WANT TO PREEN
IT, I UNDERSTAND.
UNDERSTAND.
>> YOU NEED TO CHECK YOUR
[BLEEP] ATTITUDE.
>> THE OTHER ALDERMAN JUMPED IN
THE ALDERMAN LOPEZ ON THE MAYOR
WERE THE ONLY ONES TRADING
PROFANITIES.
ANOTHER OLDER WOMAN WAS SAYING
THIS IS A TOTAL BLANK SHOW AND
ADDED THAT SHE’D NEVER SEEN
BLANK LIKE THIS BEFORE IT.
ONE ALDERMAN FINALLY SPOKE UP
SAYING MANY PEOPLE IN THE CITY
WERE LISTENING TO THE CALL
INCLUDING CHILDREN.